So if we talk about quantifications,
is there a formula for risk or
the risk exposure we have?
Risk is really, we said, how likely,
the probability of an adverse
security event happening.
So the first thing you have to say,
well there is a threat out there,
they may come after me.
I have some controls in place, but
they may be able to get around them.
And actually, I might get compromised,
may experience a breach or
whatever it is.
So what is the likelihood of that?
So you have to have the probability,
then you have to multiple by
the impact of that adverse event.
It's going to cost me $10
million to deal with that.
Well, the probability is half.
That's way too much.
But if it is half and
it's going to cost you $10 million,
your risk is $5 million.
We said quantifying, of course we had
to quantify both of these quantities.
The probability, as well as the impact
or the loss that you're going to suffer
as a result of the adverse
event that we're talking about.
So there's something
called risk leverage,
because we like to reduce
our risk exposure.
And one way we can do that is by having
some sort of a control in place.
A control we know comes with a cost.
So risk leverage is for a given control.
Talking about quantifying it and
then sort of, if it's too high,
you don't like it, we can try to reduce
it by putting in one or more controls.
So when you put a control you can ask
what the risk level of that control is.
So, the way to sort of compute that
is that you say, what was my risk
exposure before or without the control
that is under consideration?
That's without deploying that.
Minus the risk exposure after
this control is deployed.
This difference really is nothing but
the amount by which the risk is reduced
because of this control that we're
going to put into our enterprise.
So, that's the decrees in risk
divided by the cost of that control
that we're talking about.
We've been saying,
we have to have cost benefit analysis.
This is how much risk.
This is what happens to risk
if we do something about
unacceptable level of risk.
So this is the cost of that control,
that we have in the denominator here.
So, if you divide the reduction
in risk by the cost,
that gives you the risk leverage.
For any control that you have,
risk leverage should be greater than 1.
It makes no sense for it to be less than
1 because, in that case you're saying,
your risk reduction actually
is smaller than the cost.
It's not very smart that
you pay more and, overall,
you're not in a better place than you
were before in terms of the cost and
whatever risk that you have.
So, this is how we compute the leverage,
and whenever you talk about
a particular control, if you do this and
the value is not greater than 1,
then of course that control
should not be considered.